[Music]
hey guys
welcome to this complete angular
tutorial angular is a full-fledged
javascript front-end framework used to
create
single-page applications applications
like gmail
upwork nike and forbes among others
are built using angular now there's a
great demand for angular developers in
the market today
so if you wish to learn angular then
you're in the right place
this complete tutorial will introduce to
you the fundamental concepts of this
framework
first we'll start off by understanding
what exactly angular is
then i'll help you create a simple hello
world application
and teach the basic file system and
libraries of the application
then we learn about the basic building
blocks of angular that is components
after that we'll dive into advanced
topics like angular dependency injection
forms services angular bootstrap and
angular routing
after that we'll compare angular with
other front-end
javascript libraries like react and view
next we'll have a look at what's new
with the latest angular version
that is angular 10 and lastly i'll
present to you
angular interview questions that will
help you crack your next interview but
before we begin
if you haven't subscribed to our channel
already
make sure to click the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
in this session we're gonna cover the
topic of what
is angular i'm sure all of you use
mobile and web applications
be it from social media to health care
e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe
now the main reason we use these apps is
that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface
but how are they developed to provide
such reliability
one of the frameworks that is widely
used to build such robust
apps is angular so let's dive into the
session now
so here is a list of topics that we're
going to be covering
first up we'll see why angular was
introduced
then what is angular features of angular
angular architecture advantages and
limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we'll look at some of the
companies that deploy angular
so without further delay let's begin
why angular now javascript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language
it is written into html documents
enabling interactions with web pages in
many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost
pervasive support it is exceptionally
well suited to develop modern
applications
but the question arises is javascript
ideal for developing single page
applications
that require modularity testability and
other
features perhaps not however we have
a variety of frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such things
with respect to front-end development
angular and javascript
together bring in structure and
consistency to your web applications
and also provide scalability and
maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications
so now the question arises what exactly
is
angular angular is an
open source javascript framework written
completely in typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications
and is maintained by google angular as a
framework provides a few advantages
while also providing a standard
structure for developers
it is designed for web desktop and
mobile platforms
if you have a doubt here as to what
exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications
are basically applications that get
loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions
does not lead to loading of subsequent
pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page
so these single page applications are
primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing we have the document
object model
type script data binding and testing now
let's look at them
one by one now the document object model
treats an xml or an html document
as a tree structure now here every node
in the tree structure
defines an object representing a part of
your document
angular uses the regular dom now let's
suppose
you've made 10 updates on a single html
page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding dom
or the tree structure needs to be
updated now
angular updates the entire tree
structure of html tags
moving on to our next feature we have
typescript
now typescript defines a set of types
to javascript which helps you write
javascript that is
easier to understand now all the
typescript code compiles down to basic
javascript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not
mandatory for developing an angular
application but it is highly recommended
the main reason is highly recommended is
that it offers better syntactic
structure
while making the code base easier to
understand and maintain
now typescript can be installed as an
npm package
now to do that you just have to run the
command npm install hyphen g
type script on your command prompt next
up is data binding now data binding is a
process
that allows you to manipulate web page
elements
using the web browser now it mainly
employs dynamic html
and does not require complex scripting
or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials games etc now incremental
display of a web page
makes data binding extremely convenient
when pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular
it uses two-way data binding so any
changes
meeting the ui element is reflected in
the corresponding model state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state
are reflected onto the ui state this
allows the framework to connect the dom
to the model data via the controller
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses jasmine to run its various
tests
the jasmine framework allows various
functionalities
to write different kinds of test cases
karma is a task runner
for the tests that use a configuration
file
to set the startup reporters and testing
framework
so with that we've covered the features
of angular
so let's go ahead and understand the
architecture of angular
now angular is a full-fledged mvc
framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured
and offers bi-directional data flow and
updates to real dom
mvc short for model view controller
is an architectural pattern that
separates the application layer
into model view and controller the model
here
relates to all the data related logic
view on the other hand
is used for ui logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view moving on let's look at the
advantages of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components that can pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data
from your javascript code to the view
and react to user
events without having to write any code
yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write
modular services and have them injected
wherever they are needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the same
don't worry if you can't wrap your head
around these topics
we're going to discuss them further in
the coming videos
next advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up
with testability in mind you can
literally test
every part of your application
comprehensive
angular is a full-fledged framework and
provides
out-of-the-box solutions for server
communication
routing and more lastly we have
excellent browser compatibility
angular is cross platform and browser
compatible
an angular application can typically run
on all browsers
beat chrome firefox safari and platforms
like windows mac os
and linux now many versions of angular
have been released
ever since its inception all of these
versions
have added to the efficient working of
the framework
now here are two different versions
released first up
was angular 1. it was built on
javascript
and completely based on controllers next
release
was angular 2. now this incorporated the
component-based approach
wherein the entire ui was divided into
several components
and lastly integrated to give the final
logic
next was angular 4 it included router
updation
angular cli or command line interface
1.0 was introduced
however not deployed in this release the
angular cli was optimized
and commands like ng update and ng add
were added
in the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced
which provided tips in cli about the
functions being used
in angular 8 iv renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9.
now this came with the better framework
and angular material
now this completely switched to the iv
renderer as a default compiler
now that we've learnt about the pros of
using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
first up is a sleep learning curve now
since
angular is a complete full-fledged
framework
it becomes difficult for learners to
begin with
you need to be acquainted with simple
topics and then move on to more advanced
topics to become proficient in this
language
next up is limited seo options now
angular offers limited seo options and
poor accessibility to search engine
crawlers it's verbose and complex
now a common issue faced by the angular
community
is the verbosity of the framework it
also
poses to be complex compared to other
front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular
is poor migration now it becomes
difficult
to port legacy code to angular style
architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
backward compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted
with basic topics in angular some of
them
are directives modules declarators
components services dependency injection
pipes and templates now once you've
mastered your basics
you will want to go and understand more
advanced topics
such as change detection zones
aot compilation and rx.js
however the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut
in the beginning it could be a little
intimidating but once you start using
the tool
it becomes way more easier to comprehend
and understand what is going on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use
angular today many top tier companies
like nike
forbes google hbo sony
upwork among others readily deploy
angular
so moving on let's look at the
prerequisites for angular
first up we have node.js angular uses
node.js
as its base for a large part of its
build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have nodejs
installed on your environment
so head to their official website and
download the latest release
for your corresponding operating system
next up is the angular cli now this
command line interface is a tool
that makes it easier to bootstrap and
develop your angular applications
now to install the latest version run
the command
npm install hyphen g at angular
front cli you gotta run this command on
your command prompt and finally to
confirm installation
check for its version now the next thing
that you will need
is an ide or a text editor to type your
code
now there are several ides that you can
choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout
so it is available on all platforms so
go ahead and download it if you haven't
already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites i think you're ready to
create your first angular application
so let's head to our vs code and begin
here i've created a folder called
angular on my desktop and
opened it on my visual studio code so to
create your app
you need to open the terminal just go
here and
select new terminal
and now type in the command ng
new and provide the name for your app
so i'm just gonna say hello world so now
this
is going to create just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command
it will automatically generate a
skeleton application under the folder
that is hello world in our case
and it includes a bunch of files and
installs all the necessary dependencies
for the angular application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say cd hello world
and now use the command ng serve
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser
and type in localhost 4200.
once you do that you can see your ui
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser
and it says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application so let's go back to our vs
code
now as you can see here there are many
files and
folders that are created right so let's
look at a few of them of course we can't
explain
everything but i'll rush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component
now the root component here is the
index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most
important thing in the file is this app
root
element so what this does is it's
basically the marker
for loading your application code so
this is extremely important
so the next important file is the
main.ts
now this is the part of the
bootstrapping piece all right
so the index.html file is responsible
for deciding
which files are to be loaded correct the
main.ts file on the other hand
identifies which angular module is to be
loaded when the application
starts so this is just a brief
explanation
as to what they are doing next we have
the
app folder now here we have the
app.module.ts file
now this application module file can be
thought of as the code configuration of
your application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts so these are all
typescript files hence the extension ts
now this file basically is the root
component of your application
and then we have the html file for the
same which defines the appearance of
what you can see on your browser so let
me just change the message that is being
displayed
so i'll say hey
welcome to this angular
tutorial so let's save this and when we
go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser
so this was just a brief explanation of
what happens in the background of your
application
first we'll get acquainted to what
exactly angular components are
then i'll help you create an angular
component by showing a quick demo
and lastly we'll learn about component
decorator metadata but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our channel if
you love watching new and interesting
technology videos
also hit the bell icon to never miss an
update so what exactly are
angular components now i'm sure
everybody uses web applications
and one of the most widely used
applications is gmail correct
now to help you understand what
components are consider them as
lego blocks now they basically are
combined together to form the final
application
so in this case here we have the logo
component
then you have a sign in component an
image component and then a create
account component
now all of these components generally
don't affect the working of each other
but however when embedded they define
the ui of your application
so i hope you understood what components
are so to go ahead
let's discuss some of its common
features now firstly
they are the building blocks of an
application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component
and then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
detectives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series
but to give you an idea there are three
types of directives you have the
structural directives
the attribute directives and the
component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template
now components are typically custom html
elements
and each of these elements can
instantiate only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when i show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component
now this class is then decorated with
the at component decorator
now the decorator accepts a metadata
object that gives information about the
component
now a component must belong to the ng
module
in order for it to be usable by another
component or application
and finally components control their
runtime behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks
so this was just a brief introduction to
what angular components
are now you will only be able to
understand the working of components
when i show it to you practically so
let's head over to a visual studio code
now here back in my vs code i've created
a folder called angulardemo within which
i've created an angular application
called demo components
once executed the browser looks
something like this
so if you haven't watched our previous
video on
getting started with angular that is
angular hello world
i highly suggest you go through that
video first it helps you create your
first angular application
so um now let's go ahead and create
our first component now the command used
to create our component is ng
gc and your component name once executed
it creates
four different files now let's just see
how this works on
rvs code now what you can do is head to
your terminal
and type in the command ng
g c and provide a name for your
component
for example i'm going to just call my
component text component
all right so what it does is that it
creates
four different files you can see you
have four different files
that have been created and finally it
updates
the file that is app.module.ts
indicating that this
new component has been created so
here in your source folder within which
there's an app folder
and again here you can see that your
four different files have been created
first is the html file where you can
define all the code that you want
for your component next you have the css
file for your
styling then you have the dot ts file
which includes
the component decorator and finally you
have spec.ts which is basically a unit
test file
all right and then in your app.module.ts
you can observe that the component that
you've created that is text component
has been imported
that is what the message conveys here
all right now let's go back to our
app.component.html
now this basically has all the code for
your application so let me just get rid
of it
[Music]
and i'm just gonna display a basic
heading saying hello
welcome all right so let me save it
and if you go ahead and look at your
browser hello welcome message is
displayed
now let's go back to our component dot
html file
and here let me provide
a message
[Music]
let me say h 3
and let me display a message saying
welcome
to this tutorial
on angular components all right
now in your text component dot ts file
which is your typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component
now go ahead and copy this and in your
final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom html tag
with the selector that you just copied
now this indicates
that the component that you just created
that is the text component
is being incorporated in the final
render so what happens
is that whatever is defined in the
component.html file
is also being rendered in your final
output so
when i save this let's go ahead and
check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed
so this was a simple creation of a
component
now for this let's give it some styling
so
here go to your dot css file and provide
some styling
see for example here i just say
text line
and let me say center and also in my
app.component.cs i'm going to give the
same thing
and say each one
text align is center
all right so let me save this and there
we go
now we can also create multiple
components and define the tags in the
app component
now the components are executed
sequentially so now let's create another
component
just to give you a brief insight into it
let's say nggc
image component now here i'm going to be
adding
the simply learn logo so i'll show you
how that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created
with four files again so in my assets
folder here
i've added the logo so what i can do
is back in my html file i can go ahead
and create
an image tag so first let me just
display another
message here just to avoid any confusion
and let me say this is the image
component and then
let me say image
source equals so the source is basically
assets
[Music]
slash logo dot png
and class equals
center
all right so you can also head to your
css file and provide
any sort of styling that you need so let
me just say
text align
to be center and then
let's create a styling for the image
and here i mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this and from the dot cs
file
let's copy the selector and create a
custom html tag
in our final component.html file
so there we go let's save this and check
the output
and there we go first the hello welcome
message is displayed
next you have the message displayed from
the first component and then you have
the second component
so this is how you can create your own
components
and don't forget to incorporate these
selectors into your final html file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as
mentioned earlier the at component
decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object
first up is the selector now basically
the selector
is a css selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the html tag that is
included in the parent component
you can create your own html tag however
the same has to be included in the
parent component
so to help you understand that better
let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here the selector says text component
correct for the time being let's change
it
to say n component
all right now when you save it and look
at the browser
the message is not displayed so what we
can do
is you can copy this selector
and then include this here
and now you can see that the same
component has been rendered onto your
output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view
now the template can be used to provide
some particular
markup the markup could typically
include some headings or paragraphs
that are displayed on the ui next up we
have template url
now it is the url for the external file
containing the template for the view
so here you can see this is basically
the external file
that contains the template for the view
next up you have styles
now these are also inline defined styles
that can be applied to the components
view
so any code that you provide in the dot
css file can also be included here
next you have the style urls now this is
a list of urls to your style sheets
that are applied on your components view
next up you have providers now this is
again an
array where certain services can be
registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern
and finally i'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin what exactly is
dependency injection
so let's consider this i'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept
of components the entire ui of the
application
is divided into several components now
what if all of these components
perform similar tasks be it accessing
the database
rendering images etc now instead of
writing the same piece of code for every
component you could write the code once
and then perhaps
inject the same code into every
component now this
is supported by dependency injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes
a and b now let's assume that a uses the
objects of class b
and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of class b
is created so that a can accesses
objects
but using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects
outside of the class that depend on them
so dependency injection
or di keeps the core more flexible
testable and mutable
also classes can inherit external logic
without having to
create on its own and lastly gi benefits
directives
pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider class postal details
that is dependent on the number and the
address class
in the postal details class the
constructor creates
copies of the number and address so when
you instantiate
a new postal details class the
constructor instantiates a unique number
and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code
let's assume that the number and address
class constructors now accept
parameters when we change the numbers
class
the postal details class gets broken now
to overcome this what we need to do is
we need to pass
parameter to the number constructor so
this applies
to address as well the first drawback of
using this traditional method
is that the code is not very flexible
anytime the dependencies change
the postal details class needs to be
changed as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address
even if you change the number and
address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this
we make use of dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern
where a class receives its dependencies
from an external source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example
we have moved the definition of
dependencies from
inside the constructor to the
constructor's parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create
the dependencies anymore so with that we
overcome the drawbacks of not using di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is
let's look at a simple demonstration to
understand the concept better
now services classes modules
competence all of these are benefactors
of dependency injection
so in the demo i'm going to be showing
how dependency injection can be used
with the help of services
and injecting these services into
classes so the main
uh thought behind this is normally
components are used to
ensure just a good user experience these
components do not
generally execute tasks so to execute
these tasks we make use of services
so a component can delegate tasks like
fetching data from the server
any network related issues etc to a
particular service
and these services can be made available
to components
with the same thought what i'm going to
be doing is i'll be creating
a service that performs the task of
displaying an employee list
later we're going to inject this service
into the class using
dependency injection so let's head to
our visual studio code for the
demonstration
all right so as discussed i'll have to
first create a component
that displays a button for the employee
and then i have to create a service
class and inject it into my component
now this service holds the employee
details such as name
employee id email id etc
so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type nggc
and the name of the component i'm
providing is
amp info if getting your learning
started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
all right so as you can see here in my
app folder i have
the component with four different files
all right so the next thing we have to
do is we have to create a service
so to create that we make use of the
command
ng g s you can either give s
or service and the service name i'm
providing is records
so let me just say records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is
a spec.ts file and the dot ts file
all right so now the service contains
all the employee data that needs to be
displayed
right so let's go ahead and write the
data so first we're going to make use of
three arrays i'm going to be displaying
employee records for three employees
so i'll have to create three arrays and
provide certain information
so let's go ahead and do that
all right so the area i'm creating is
called info one
for the first employee and i'm going to
be
passing
information like name employee id and
the email id so the arrays of type
string
and within which let me just mention the
details
i'm giving random information i'm just
saying
adam taylor
and some random employee id
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so i'm going to be creating
three records so i'll just copy the same
thing and paste for the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and let me change the name of the idea
as well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component
we make use of the method for the same
right so this method returns the
employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
i'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot in four one
all right i'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
i'm just going to return different
arrays here
all right and lastly info 3 all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component
we need three more arrays right three
more arrays that will receive this data
let's go back to our component dot ts
file here
and then type in the following code
so i've created three arrays again or in
four received one
two and three now what we need to do is
we have to accept the information that
is being sent
from the service correct now as
i mentioned services are implemented
with the help of dependency injection
so what we need to do is we'll have to
first import the service
into the component.ts file the key
reason behind doing this
is that when angular creates this
component an instance of the service
class is
also made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so i'll say import
[Music]
records services
i'm sorry service from
and let's say records dot service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also
declare this instance that is being
created in the providers area of the
component
all right so
let's just say providers
and then say records service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class right however to access
this instance an
object is also created so this object
will in turn access the methods and
variables of the service class
so for that we have to create another
object so let's do that here in our
constructor method
let's say constructor
private and the object i'm creating is
called our service you can give a name
of your choice and then i'm going to
just say records
service all right now this
object will help me retrieve data from
the service
so let's go ahead and use this in order
to get
the employee details all right so i've
created three different
methods here get info from service class
2
1 and 3 and these methods will retrieve
the data
and add it to our array here that is
info received all right and lastly
we'll have to create an unordered list
in our html file here we haven't added
anything
so let me get rid of this
so now i have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the ui
right
so as you can see i've created buttons
for three different employees
and then i've made use of a bootstrap
class called
list group info and then i've
interpolated info which displays the
contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot ts
file
we have to bind them with the button so
since it is bound with the click event
every time you click on the button the
information is
displayed so now the last thing we have
to do is we'll have to create a custom
html tag for the component
and then add it to the main component so
let's just
do that let me copy this here
and then in my appcomponent.html let me
get rid of this
and then let me just create this i've
just created
the custom html tag for my component
and now just to beautify the code i'll
write a heading
and let's say employee
details and then i'll also add
the simply learn logo say image
source
[Music]
i've added the image here so let me just
say
logo dot png
i've also added some styling to it all
right
so now let me just save this and have a
look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then
employee details heading and then we
have three different
buttons created that is employee one two
and three and when i
click on it the information of
the employee is displayed the name the
id
and their email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection
and inject a service class into a
component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
we'll understand what angular forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control
and group control and we learn all of
this with the help of a simple demo
so without further ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now i'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling
correct be it your login credentials or
your sign up
forms or any sort of registration forms
etc
so forms are an integral part of a web
application
you need forms to update your profile or
to enter sensitive information
or also to perform any sort of data
related tasks
so now let's look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one so
talking about template driven approach
in this method the conventional form tag
is used to create
forms so angular automatically
interprets
and creates a form object with the help
of the directives
now controls can be added to the form
using the ng model
tag now multiple controls can be grouped
using the ng control group module so it
basically uses several module classes to
provide controls
now if you don't get this don't worry
you'll understand better when i'm
showing you the demo
next up is json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as json values
when the submit method
is called lastly basic html validations
can be used
to validate the form fields in the case
of custom validations
directives can be used so arguably this
method is the simplest way to create
an angular form so moving on to the
active approach
now this approach is the programming
paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the anti
pattern of updating the data model
by a two way data binding so it does not
use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous
and can be unit tested with synchronous
programming techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control
and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like
name age and location now a form control
is basically a class that enables
validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
now these instances help check the
values of the field
and see if they're either touched
untouched dirty
pristine valid invalid and so on so this
allows you to check every field for the
value it makes it easier to understand
which field's value is invalid or which
field has not been entered
etc now moving on to form
group so a form group class
represents a group of controls a form
can have multiple group controls
the form group returns true if all the
controls
are valid and provides validation errors
if there are any
so i hope this was clear so moving ahead
let's look at the demo to explain all of
these features i'm sure it will become
extremely clear once you look at the
demo so for that
let's head to our vs code so back in my
vs code
i've created a component called form
component
and i've also included the simply learn
logo just to beautify
the appearance so once you execute the
code
this is what you're going to see on your
browser so you just have the logo at the
moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to
import the forms module all right
so oh uh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is
so we're going to be creating a user
registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last name
email id and a password all right so now
let me show you how to import the forms
module
so in your main app.module.ts file
you will have to import forms module
from angular forms
all right and then in your imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that
let's go ahead and start our form
creation
so here in my component.html
let's enclose the entire form within a
div tag
so here let me say div
class is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now i'm going to create a div class for
every field
so say div
class equals
form group
i'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag for
basically it's the first name so let me
just
say first name
and the tab will basically have first
name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right so this we have to do for
all the other fields so let me just copy
this
and paste it like four times
i'll also add the tag three
for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type submit
let's just say submit on the button so
now
let's go ahead and change these values
here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have password so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our uh user
registration form ready
but i would like to uh align it
to the center so let me just do that
so here in my css file i'm just going to
align all the div tags to the center and
the label tag to the left
so let me save this and look at the
browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form with a logo
so this is how you create a simple form
now we have to add a directive called ng
model
now this directive when added into the
input tag
will provide form controls to every
input field
all right so here let's just go ahead
and say ng
model that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for
every other field
all right let me save this and back in
my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like ng untouched
ng pristine ng valid are added
right so this indicates that angular has
recognized the form tag
and it has added these classes to the
form as well as all the fields
so this is achieved when you add the ng
model directive in your input tag
now back in my vs code now every form
has an
output property attached to it called ng
submit
all right so this property can be bound
within a method that
method called the subbit method so once
submitted this method is called right so
once we click on the submit button this
method has to be called
so to include that we have to just
save form
ng submit
equals
submit all right
so now we have to define the submit
method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our
component.ts file and let me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function called
subnet and then here let me just
console log form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser
so first let's go to our console
and when i click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step
is to generate javascript representation
now we'll have to make use of another
directive called ng form
that is assigned to a template variable
okay
so this javascript representation
helps with validating all the fields so
i'll help you understand that better
so back in our html file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login all right
and say ng form
okay now the mgform object includes the
javascript representation
so now while you're calling the submit
method you're going to pass
login as a parameter so let's just say
login here and in my ts
file again let's just say login
and along with it i want login to be
displayed so
i say login again so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's
click on submit
and now here you can see the javascript
representation
so within form i can
check for email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you
all information about the particular
field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information
so we're going to learn about that in
our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that
incorrect fields are not submitted
is by disabling the submit button
correct
now apart from this you can also specify
certain properties in your input tag
for the corresponding input field
now um let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty
and the form only accepts names with the
minimum length of 2 and the maximum
length
of 7 all right so here
in my input tag i just mentioned a
required
meaning this field cannot be empty
and min length
to 2 and
max length
to say 7 all right
so to check this let's go to our browser
and here let me submit the form without
filling the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when i submit it and i look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name you can see that
an error is shown here it says
required equals true that means that
there is
one error now you can make use of these
form control objects
you can leverage form control objects to
ensure field validation
and display a message whenever an error
occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like
errors or invalid or touched
all of these properties or objects need
to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create a variable
let me call it
name and
let's say ng model
all right here the variable name
receives the control
object so here back in my browser when i
submit again without
the first name you can see that the
invalid
property is set to true correct
so this helps us use this property to
alert the user with the help of a simple
if logic
so back in my vs code
let me create another div tag
within which i mentioned ng if
within which i'm going to use a simple
if logic so let's say mgf
name which is our template variable
name dot touched
and named dot invalid
is true
right then i'm going to alert so i'm
gonna
make use of an alert here let's say
alert danger
all right so in my css file i'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're gonna have the background color
red
for danger all right and here i'm gonna
display the message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement
say suppose the length of the first name
is too short then you can alert the user
with a different message
or suppose they have missed out on
filling a form field
then you can again alert the user so you
can basically make use of the nested if
condition
right now just try and help you
understand that better let me just
show it to you now back in my html
file instead of invalid
let me have another tag a paragraph tag
within which i make use of ng if again
now ng if name dot
errors dot required
is true then i display the message
first name
required all right
and if
the length of the first name is
not two
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2
then i'm going to display another
message so let me just say
name dot errors dot min length
if this is true then i'm going to say
sorry
short first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when i proceed without providing the
name it says first name required
but when i type in one character it says
sorry
short first name but if i type in
another character it accepts
so i hope this made you understand how
form validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now i highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects
uh trust me it's really fun so
i hope this tutorial helped you out i'm
sure you all know that
an angular app is divided into several
components
for example you have the logo component
you have the sign in component an image
component
and say a create account component now
these
components are standalone and each of
them
represents a part of the user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed
common tasks for example accessing the
database
or rendering images on the view tasks
like those
now instead of having to write the code
for
every component you can just make use of
angular services now the service can be
written
once and then injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable
or a feature that an application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once
and avoid rewriting of it now the same
code can be injected into several
components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure
a good user experience now that is the
extent of it
components make sure that whatever is
being rendered onto the screen
is right and pristine but
in order to execute tasks we make use of
services
and this approach is ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks
like fetching data from the server
validating user
input or logging directly to the console
to a particular service and these
tasks can be made available to any
component in the app
so now let's talk about a few features
of angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class
with an at injectable decorator
this decorator tells angular that the
class is a service
and can be injected into components that
need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code
they can also inject other services as
dependencies
now these services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the backend
now for example if you want to make ajax
calls
you can have methods to those calls in
the service
and then use it as a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data
among several components in angular
services are singleton meaning that only
a single
instance of a service gets created and
the same instance
is used by each and every building block
in the application
and finally a service can be registered
as a part of a module
or it can be registered as a part of the
component
now to register it as a part of the
component you'll have to specify it
in the provider's array of the module
i'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better
if we look at a simple demo so in the
next section
we're going to look at a demo but before
that let me tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create
an employee details list say for example
you will have employee information like
name employee id
and their email id will create a
database of say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button
it displays the information about that
particular employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employee's details
so without delay let's head to our vs
code
and start learning angular services
hands-on
so here first i've created a folder
called demo underscore angular
within which i've created a file called
hello world
so this was previously used for a
tutorial so
the name is just hello world so don't
get confused
however when you look at the browser
i've written
an initial code here which is angular
services and i have the simply learn
logo
so back in my browser this is what the
ui looks like
so uh to so to understand the concept of
angular services first let's go ahead
and create a component
so here i am going to say ng g
c e
info i'm creating a component
for employee information
so as you can see inside my
app file we have the e info
component which has these four files so
if you're wondering
what exactly components are and how this
is working
then i highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so i'm just typing in the command ng
g service here g stands for generate
and we're generating a service and the
name of the service that i'm providing
is data so now it creates
a service which is going to be
a dot ts file so you can observe that
dot service is appended
this indicates that it is a service all
right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details
correct so for that in my component.ts
file
i'm going to create an array that
displays the employee information
in our case i'm creating uh three
different employee records
so for that i'll have three different
arrays so let me just
call the arrays info
received one indicating this is the
information
of first employee and this is going to
be of type
string and i'll just initialize it to
null
for now all right and i'm going to
create
two other arrays
and let me just change
the name of that is all right so now
uh to retrieve the information i'll have
to create
a method again i'm creating three
methods for
uh the three different employee records
so i'm going to call the array get info
from service 1 indicating it's again for
employee 1
and i'm just gonna leave it as it is for
now i'll tell you how the information is
being received
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records
so let me just copy paste
and here i'm just going to change
the name of the methods all right
so this is the initial code for
retrieving information
however we'll have to create the
employee record in our service
so back here in my data.ts file
what i'm going to do is i'll create
three different records for the
employees
so let me say info 1
which is going to be of type string
all right and let me just give
a random names say for example i say
john
matthew
[Music]
all right and employee id say
e 354
and let me just give a random
email id and say jm at abc.net
all right so i'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh
records so let me just create
another one and call it info two
and the name i'm providing is say
rob wilson with
a different employee id say 673
and i'm just going to make it rw at
abc.net and another record
for employee number three
and i'm just gonna say rose
[Music]
adams
with some employee id
and an email id all right
so now we've created the employee
records
so what i have to do is i have to create
a method
that returns these employee records
correct
so for that i'm just going to create
another
method called get info 1
which is of type string
and it just returns this
dot info 1. all right
similarly for the rest of the two
records i'm just going to retrieve them
[Music]
let's say in 4 2 and get info
2 and again
i'm just going to make it get in for
three
and this is gonna return in four three
all right so i'm sure you've got an idea
as to what i'm doing here
so basically this information is going
to be retrieved
in our employee component correct
so for that i'll have to make use of
dependency injection
so here i'll have to import the service
that i've created so let's go ahead and
say
import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right from
[Music]
slash data dot service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to
tell angular that when the component is
created
the service instance is also created and
this
instance is being used to perform
particular tasks
and for that we'll also have to include
this in our providers area
so here let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created
we make use of a property so
this property basically allows us to
access
all the methods that are defined in the
service class
all right so here in my constructor
method
i'm just going to say private
and you can give any name for your
property and here i'm just
giving the name d service
all right and which is of type
data service
all right so now with the help of this
property i can
retrieve information from the service
class so here i'm just going to save
this dot info receipt
equals this dot d service
dot get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls
the get info one method in our service
which returns the information of the
first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is
infor received one so similarly for the
next
two methods i'm just to use the same
piece of code
let me just change it here
and same for the third one
all right so now that we have the logic
behind
what is being displayed let's go ahead
and create
the ui for it here in my html file
i'm going to create an unordered list
[Music]
and now i'm going to make use of
the ng
for director to uh basically
loop over the record and display
everything so
for that i have to make use of a
particular variable so i'll just
say let info
of info received so
um you can check here in our ts file the
array is info received correct so i'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first in
employee record i'm just going to
say info received one
all right and let me just create a class
a bootstrap class
of list group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
info all right that is basically going
to display
what the information holds what the info
variable holds
all right and here as well let me create
a bootstrap class
called list
group all right i hope this was
clear to you so basically here the
information is being retrieved with the
help of
this method right that is get info from
service one so
in order to call this method we'll have
to bind it
with a button all right so that's what
we're gonna do
let's just copy this
and here i'm gonna create a button
all right and the type
is button
[Music]
with name button again
all right so i'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when i click on
it this particular
method gets called all right i'm just
pasting the method here and finally
let's just provide the name employee one
for the button all right
so uh similarly we'll have to do the
same for
the other two records as well
let me just make this look better all
right
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to paste the same
twice
and here i'm going to just change the
names i'll say
2 here and this is again for employee 2
and i'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employee
i'm sorry it's going to be in 4 received
2 this is going to be in 4 received
3 and finally employee 3
all right and lastly we'll have to
include the selector that is
app hyphen e info in our main
component or html so here
let me just
create a custom tag all right and save
this
so now let's go back to our browser and
see what it looks like
so here you can see that three different
buttons have been created
for employee one two and three and when
you click on it
it retrieves the information that is the
name
the employee id and their email ids so
we've successfully
created an angular service and injected
it
into our component to retrieve
information
all right so now the last part of the
use case that we discussed
was uh to add another detail
that is the employee detail in the
record all right
so for that we'll have to take input
from the user
and in our case we're taking the
location now
we're also adding the same location for
all three employees
so this is what services do you know
they
can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can
tweak the code a little bit and you can
change the entire
uh view of your application you can add
information you can delete you can
retrieve you can alter etc
all right so for that what we're going
to do is back
in the html file we'll create a form
that basically takes the input so
i'm just going to say um
form all right
within which i'm going to be defining a
div class
[Music]
within which i'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside of which i'll have the input tag
of type
text and
the name i'm going to be providing it
will be location
all right
[Music]
and we'll have a value and i'll just
leave it blank and finally i'll have ng
model
so if you're confused as to what i'm
doing here then i suggest you watch
the angular forms uh video
it basically teaches you uh how to work
around with
angular forms all right and now
after this we're gonna have a button
so let me say button
all right
[Music]
and i'm gonna just say add info
okay
all right so now when i'm creating the
form
i'll also have to create a template
variable
to access all the values within my form
so if i have to access the location
then i need a variable to access it so
here let me just go ahead
and create a template variable let me
call it frm and i'm going to make use of
the ng
form directive so this tells angular
that this variable can be used
to access all the values within the form
and since i'm using form here i'll have
to import it
in my module file
so here i just go ahead
and say import forms module
from angular forms and here in my
imports
[Music]
i'll just say forms module
okay so i've imported the forms module
so now
back in my html file what i'm going to
do
is that i'll have to make use of this
template variable
to update my information correct so
i'll have to create another method
that will update information into the
records
so here in my component.ts file
i'll have to create another method
and i'm going to call this method update
info method all right
and this basically takes in the
template variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do is
that
it updates the record correct
so i'm going to say this dot
d service dot
add info now you must be wondering what
ad
info is i'll just let you know in a
minute
and and the value that i'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've
provided as an input
which is nothing but form dot value
dot location all right
so now what happens is that i'll have to
again specify
what ad info is and this method is going
to be defined
in the service file correct
so here i'm going to create another
method that's add info
and i'm gonna pass info as a parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays so since i'm going to be
pushing the same information into all of
these arrays that is info one in photo
and info three
i'm just going to say this dot info one
dot push off info
[Music]
all right and uh the same for
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right so what exactly
i'm doing is that i have
i have a method called add info which
gets information
from the component all right and it
basically pushes this information
into the array and also i have to return
it
so i'll say return this dot
info one
all right and i'll save it and
here we have another method called
update
info which basically calls uh the add
info method in our service and passes
the value to it and in my html file
also note that the button type here is
submit
and not button so what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
uh passed on to the method that is
update info
so here i'll say ng submit
and i'm going to call the method update
info and i'm going to pass
frm as the argument
and now let's save this and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button
saying add info so now i can just go
ahead and
see type usa and when i say add
info and when i check on my
employee 1 details usa has been added to
the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so i hope this simple demo on angular
services helped you understand the
concept better
i highly recommend you play around and
explore other possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection
of html css and javascript tools
for creating and building responsive web
applications
and pages it is a free and open source
project
based on github and originally created
by twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection
of handy reusable bits of code written
in html
css and javascript it's also a front-end
development framework
that enables developers and beginners to
design
quick and responsive websites now there
are several advantages
to using bootstrap to name a few
bootstrap comes with a responsive grid
you don't have to spend time working on
your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing
images based on the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use
for your web page these components could
be navigation bars
drop downs progress bars thumbnails
etc it also offers excellent
documentation
and is customizable so bootstrap comes
in extremely handy
to create responsive user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application
so let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it first up
is by using the bootstrap cdn
or the content delivery network now this
enables users to load css javascript and
images
remotely from its servers the other
method
is to use bootstrap npm bootstrap
jquery and other packages and frameworks
can be installed
via the command prompt in the tutorial
that i am going to be showing you
i have embedded bootstrap using npm all
right
so i'm sure you only understand the
concept better when you look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap
so in this tutorial what i'm going to be
showing is the creation of a blog post
so let me show you what we're going to
be doing
so here i've created a simple blog
for simply learn and i've added the
simply learn logo
i've also written a few lines about
simply learn
and what they offer i've also mentioned
their tag line
and when you scroll down you can see
that i've mentioned
the different courses they're offering
and
when you click on the more info
button it navigates to the official page
that gives you the overview for that
particular course
so this is for lean six sigma the same
for
full stack web development as well
and the same for the last one that is
cyber security and finally i've added
a simple video here to just make it more
uh beautiful so i've added a simple
video
and lastly i've also
linked our youtube channel so when you
click on the youtube icon
it will navigate to the youtube channel
to our youtube channel here all right
so this is what we're going to be
creating
uh using angular bootstrap so i'm hoping
you're all ready for it
so without further delay let's jump in
so first
let's find the template that we want to
use for our blog
so for that i'm going to just go ahead
and say
[Music]
bootstrap blog
template and i'm just going to click on
the first
link that i get and here
you can choose a template that you like
so i'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is oh yeah this one
so which is small businesses so you can
go ahead and click on that
you can then click on live preview
and once you do that
you can just say view frame source
so here you can see that the html code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags and then you have the
title and then you also have the css
file references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the ui there's code for navigation
bar
and then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that and
lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code
and then we'll have to create components
for each of it
and then we'll include all the
components in our main
html file so that is the best practice
that angular uses so we're going to make
use of components
and you can also see that when you
scroll down you can see that
it has certain dependencies so here it
has the
bootstrap dependency and then you have
jquery so
we have to download them so we'll have
to install them
and as mentioned earlier we're going to
be installing them with the help
of npm so for that we'll have to head
back to our vs code
here back in my vs code i've created
a folder called angulardemo
and then i've also created a file called
demo components
and here i'm just going to say
cd demo components
within which i'll say npm install
jquery
[Music]
so this could take a while and once
you've installed
jquery go ahead and type npm install
bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jquery and
bootstrap so now we need to add the
references to these javascript files
to do that go to your angular.json file
and here we have to add them in our
build section
so here you can see we have styles and
scripts
so in our scripts array we define the
relative path
to these javascript files so these files
are generally
stored in your node modules so
go ahead and here you can
look for bootstrap here you go
and then in your dist file
and then click on js and then you can
see
you have bootstrap.min.js
oh well i'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my json file in my scripts
i'm gonna just paste it here and
make sure to uh make it a path by
providing
by providing forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for
jquery so here there's jquery and then
click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
[Music]
well
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here in the beginning
they've also included the css file
so we'll have to embed that as well so
here back in bootstrap
let me just add the css file as well
that's bootstrap.min.css i'm just going
to copy the relative path
and just provide it here
[Music]
let me just change these to forward
slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to copy this
and just paste it in our
[Music]
and then you can just paste it here
all right so i think we've
added all the dependencies and the
custom style sheet and everything so
now let me just close all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and
take the code from the source here so
i'm just going to copy
the body tag all right
so i'm going to copy this till the
footer
and then i'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier i will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the ui in these
components
so let me just see if i've got
everything here
okay so i'll be creating
four components the first one will be
for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be to
display
the courses that we're providing and
then lastly we'll have the
footer component right so first let's
create these components
i've also created a components folder
here in my
app folder so i just have to
type in the command ng gc
first we'll create the component for the
top navigation bar so i'm just saying
nggc so i'm just gonna say components
slash nav bar
[Music]
all right so uh the component has been
created so what i'm going to do is i'll
just
copy this
[Music]
and paste it here
[Music]
all right and the next component i'm
going to be creating
is for the introduction right so i'll
say
ng g c
[Music]
components slash intro
all right so
so i will have to take
this code here i'm also going to be
including the call to action
part so i'll just
copy paste this one in my intro.html
file
[Music]
so let me do that and then i'm going to
have the
main course content component so
for that i'll say nggc
components slash courses
[Music]
and we're going to copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until till the footer
[Music]
let me just add it here and finally
we're going to create
the component for the footer so i'll say
ng gc
components slash footer
and the last part of the code i'm just
going to add it there
all right so now we'll have to create
the custom html tags for these
components and then
place it in our html file right so
first one that we created was the
navigation bar so here
head over to the ts file
just copied the selector
[Music]
and then here and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags similarly for intro
[Music]
i'm just going to copy the selector
and then for courses so
[Music]
app hyphen courses
that as well
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
paste it here
[Music]
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything
is displayed intact so here let me just
say
ng serve so when you execute the command
you can see that the template is being
displayed
so you have the navigation bar you have
the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component
right okay so now that we have the
template ready
we can go ahead and customize it
according to our needs
so now i'm going to be making a few
changes to the code we're going to add
the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tag line here
we're going to display something else
over here all right so
let's go back to our vs code to
customize and
display the final output so here
the first thing that i'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here i'm gonna
display simply learn for that
in our navbar component let's go to the
html code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just
type in simply learn
[Music]
alright so when you save it and when you
look at the browser
you can see that simply learn is
displayed
and the next thing that i want to do is
i want to add
the image right i simply learn logo
so what i've done here is i've already
added
the logo dot png file in my assets
folder
so i'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this so that's going to be in
our intro files so
here
image source is going to be
[Music]
assets slash
logo.png
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change this part of the
ui so the information that i want to
display
is this i'm going to be displaying
world's number one online bootcamp and
other information so what i'm going to
do
is back in my vs code i'm just going to
delete
this and instead of that i'm just going
to
copy this that's world's number one
online bootcamp and then within the
paragraph tag
i'll display something else so let me
get rid of this
let me just copy the information that i
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action
message i'm going to display a explore
programs message
so let's go back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here and then
lastly instead of this message here
i want to display the message uh get
certified get ahead with our programs
so back in our vs code
i'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
so when you have a look at the browser
let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message get
certified get ahead
and all of that well now what i'm going
to do
is i'm really not happy with the font
size and everything
so i'm just go ahead and add certain
styling you can customize this and
provide your own
font size and all of that so here
i'm just going to mention style
and then say font size
and i'm going to make it x x large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so i think i'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here
for our courses so back in our vis
code we'll have to go to the courses
component so here i'm gonna just uh type
in the code for
the different courses so i already have
it here
so the first thing is this message that
i want to display
let me just copy that and for our first
tag i'm just going to say
post graduate program ending six sigma
and the next information i'm going to be
providing is the duration
so here let me just get rid of this
paste that here let me just break the
line
to beautify the code and then
and here for our reference link
i already have the link here so i'm just
going to paste that
so once you click on the more info
button
it will automatically navigate to this
page
all right so let me save this
next up i'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says postgraduate program in
full stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort
so
let me paste that and also
provide a blind break and then
link i have it here so
i'm just gonna paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card i have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core
and paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same all right
so let me save this and
have a look at the browser so
you can see that the information has
been added
you can see it displays postgraduate
program in lean six sigma full stack
development and cyber security
so once i click on more info it
leads you to that page that shows the
overview
all right so now the next thing on the
agenda was to
uh display a short video and then
the link to our youtube channel so let's
go ahead and add that
in our courses component
uh so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to get the code to add
a video from google and then i'm going
to
uh provide the source which is going to
be the video that i would want to
display
so i've received the code i'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on google so
go ahead and just paste that
also for the source i have a video in my
assets folder
which i have provided here so when i
save it
and look at the browser here we go you
can see the video here
all right and once clicked it starts
playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo
for youtube and then the link to
navigate to the youtube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again i've pasted the code
for the youtube logo so here you can see
that i've added the image that is
youtube.png in my assets folder
and i've provided the source and
accordingly i've also added
the styling i've provided a white
background and i've also aligned
the text to the center of the page
all right and i've also displayed the
message saying check out
our youtube channel for technical videos
and tutorials and then i provided the
link to our
channel on youtube so let me just save
this and head back to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the youtube logo and we have the
message displayed
so once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
channel on youtube
all right so if you want you can also
change the message
here for the footer so here in
footer.html i can just
remove this and
paste this i say simply on solutions and
all rights reserved
when i save it and look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go so with the help of
bootstrap we have successfully created
a website which is basically a blog
and we've also added the reference links
and
images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements so yeah
this is it this is how you
make use of bootstrap and embed it into
your angular
for more responsive and better user
interface let's have a look
at the basics of routing now i'm sure
that you observed
that the url changes every time you
click on a particular link
or on an icon on the user interface
correct
now this basically indicates that you
are navigating throughout the
application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism
called routing routing is essentially
used
to navigate through a website or a web
application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular
routing plays a major role it is used to
create
single page applications now these
applications
are loaded just once and new content is
added dynamically
applications like google facebook
twitter and gmail are a few examples
of single page applications the best
part of using
single page applications is that it
provides an
excellent user experience and you don't
even have to wait
for new pages to load which by extension
makes
single page applications extremely fast
but how is this new content
loaded enter routing
now routing is the mechanism that as
discussed earlier
that is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now i'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better
when you work on it hands-on so in the
demo we're going to be navigating to the
login and the home pages of a web
application
with the help of routing so let's head
to our visual studio code
so basically the objective of our
application
is to navigate to home and
the login pages so when i click on the
login
icon here it loads the login
page and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home
once you click on it some new
information gets added
and the url changes with the slash home
appended
all right so this is the main objective
of our application
so to create it let's head back to our
vs code
all right so here i've created a folder
called
demo and underscore angular and i've
created a file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file
and make sure that the base tag is added
now although this is generally added
when your app is created
if it is not then add a base tag with
href attribute
which is set to a forward slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular
to construct the url while navigating
with a forward slash all right and the
next thing you want to do
is open your app.module.ts file
and check if the app routing module has
been imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your
imports array with that
the initial setup is done now to create
the nav bar
the code that i'm going to be using is
already explained in the previous video
that is
angular bootstrap i highly suggest you
go through that
video before watching this so the code
is already available i'm just going to
create
a component and write the code for it
and paste the code in it so let's do
that
let me say ng gc
navbar
[Music]
all right so this component is now
created
now here in my html file
i'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go i've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my app.component.html file
i'll just remove all the unwanted
code here and just specify the
custom html tag for my navbar
so let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when i open the browser uh
the navigation bar has been created
along with these different options
that's home
about services and login all right
and we also have the simply learn icon
here
all right now the next step is to
generate the components
to display the login page content and
the home page content
now again i have used bootstrap to
define the user interface for these
files
you can easily find the code online just
search for
bootstrap login templates and depending
on your requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create the components for
by two files that is for the home
component
and the login component so
let's go ahead and do that
ngc
i'm just going to call it login for my
login component
all right and then i'm gonna say nggc
home
for the home component
all right so i'm just going to copy the
code for the login component so back in
my login.html
file
i'll just paste the code here
okay also note that i've added
the simply learn logo in my assets
folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right so next up is the home
component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap
you might have seen that we created
three different components that is
intro courses and footer which included
the content
for the intro message for the courses
and the photo message correct so here
we're going to just paste the code for
all of these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what i'm going to do is
i'll just paste it here
[Music]
so this basically has all the content
one thing i want to tell you is that
in the previous video we made sure that
the code was written in three different
components
however for this i've just added all the
code in the same component
now i agree that this is not the best
practice so
if you want you can go ahead and create
three different components
and separate the code into these three
components
and just add the custom html tags in
your home component
i'm just hoping you're following me
right now
and also here in my assets folder i've
added
a video and the youtube logo that needs
to be displayed
when the home icon is clicked all right
so now that we've created
the home and the login components the
next step is to configure the routes for
the application
all right so here you can see that we
have a file called
app routing module.ts file so here
we have the routes and the router module
that is imported
and we also have a constant called
routes
which is strongly typed to routes from
the router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application
now each route is basically an object
with a path so here in my routes array
i'm just going to go ahead and create
the paths
that is we have two different routes
right
one is for login and one is for home so
i'm just going to create
a path object so let's say path
i'm sorry within curly braces i say path
[Music]
and then the path that i'm going to give
is
login this is basically what will appear
on the url all right and
the component that needs to be navigated
to
is nothing but the login component so
let me just say login component
as you can see the login component has
been automatically imported
now same with the home
path so let me just say path
home and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right now the next step is to link
these routes
to a button in the navbar that is the
home
and the login button right so we're
going to make use of
the nav tag and an anchor tag for this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag which encloses
the login and the home components all
right
now we're going to make use of two
directives
from the router package called router
link and router link
active now these are specified within
the anchor tag
the router link basically holds the path
to the
page and the latter that is the router
link
active specifies one or more css classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just
add
router link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're going to have another director
called
router link active
[Music]
and we're just going to say active here
[Music]
all right same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route
to your specific button on your ui
now despite of all this how are we
specifying
where these components are to be
displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router
outlet directive now again this
directive is available in the router
package
so we have to add that in our app
component.html file
so here just go ahead and type
router outlet
all right so with that we've created a
simple navigation bar
which has different options that is home
about services and link
and once the user clicks on the home
icon it displays the content that is
in the home component dot html file
and once the user clicks on the login
component
it displays the content in the
login.html file
all right it's as simple as that so now
let's go to the browser and see if it
executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once i click on the home i can hear
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section
as discussed and the most important part
is that here in our url you can see that
slash home has been appended this shows
that a route has been created that
navigates to the home component
so we've successfully created a route
here
and for login component when i click on
this icon
you can see that the path changes here
and
the login component gets displayed
all right so this is how routing is
achieved in angular
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more in this session we'll be
comparing the three cutting edge ui
development technologies that is
react.js
angular and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications
to more distributed applications where a
part of the job is done on the client
side
and a part on the server side and now
we've transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba
and all of these technologies that you
see on your screen right now are
based purely on javascript as a result
they're lightweight and aren't dependent
on any third-party runtime tools
so let's compare the three technologies
and learn about the factors that make
them stand out
so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features
use cases and where they're applied
their performance how they handle data
the languages they use and the testing
mechanisms we learn about the dedicated
user community that backs these
technologies and finally we'll see the
growth curve
first we'll look into the salient
features now react is a front-end
javascript library
while angular and vue are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably
they're significantly different now
library is a set of classes or functions
and the user is in complete control to
call them frameworks on the other hand
are like models
they have limited choices and come with
a blueprint of their own
and as a result the user doesn't have
much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications
and angular is used for single page
applications and you can also develop
hybrid applications using the stack
mainly because it's purely based on css
html javascript and jquery
single page applications as the name
suggests are built using single page
now the entire page is broken down into
several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component
handles the login the other one would
display icons and images and so on
all these bits or components are then
put together to form a single page
application
and moving on react was developed and
maintained by facebook
while angular was built by google and
vue was developed by evan unx
google employee now react represents the
view part of the mvc framework
and angular is a full-fledged mvc
framework in itself and view on the
other hand is focused on view
and the model layer of the mvc framework
now what exactly
is the mvc framework now mvc framework
is an
object oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while vue deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application
and the controller drives the
functionality of the two any changes can
be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective
in terms of react we have top websites
like facebook
instagram netflix that use react on the
other hand we have
angular that is used by nike hbo forbes
sony and vue is commonly used by
alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance
now performance is a very crucial
feature now the moment you build an html
view and render it into the browser
this view to the user is basically just
html tags
however if you look at the internal
working the code is actually converted
into a balanced tree structure
this b3 algorithm is extremely fast so
when the user makes any changes to the
ui the changes are reflected immediately
this is facilitated by the b3 algorithm
so as a result the performance is
improved so how does react make use of
this tool
it uses a virtual dom dom is an api
developed by w3c it stands for document
object model and defines how the
document is accessed and manipulated
this dom parser converts the html code
into an inverse balance tree structure
so react uses the virtual dom while
angular uses the real dom
and vue uses the virtual dom again now
the virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages
and only changes the parts that need to
be updated angular on the other hand
updates the entire tree structure
regardless of any changes made or not
and view again only updates the ones
that have changed
since there is no time spent on making
unnecessary changes to the entire tree
react is extremely fast on the other
hand real dom updation is time consuming
risky and error-prone vue also ensures
faster and bug-free performance now
let's talk about data binding
the core reason why we would use single
page applications now consider a
scenario where you log into an
e-commerce website
as the user one then you should be able
to see the items in your shopping cart
while user two
would be seeing different items in their
shopping carts and so on so identifying
the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help
of data binding data binding is a
process that allows an internet user to
manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as
calculators tutorials games etc now
react supports one way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa
angular on the other hand uses a two-way
data binding while view also uses a
similar two-way data binding
in react every time the model state
updates the view changes accordingly
however the reverse is not true
in case of angular any changes made to
the view are immediately reflected in
the model part of the architecture
view follows the same principle now this
hugely influences
the performance due to one-way data
binding react is modular and fast
improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance
and view on the other hand performs
according to the input type moving on to
scripting languages
react combines ui templates and
javascript logic
resulting in a new language called jsx
so react only requires a knowledge of
javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives
so you can create a class and then
inject it into html
angular also does something better you
can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called
typescript it is a compiled language and
is very similar to java and c-sharp in
terms of syntax
now view again uses html based template
it uses html5 throughout for the ui
and the combination of javascript for
business logic all view templates are
valid html and can be passed by html
parsers
let's move on to testing now jest is a
framework or an api that is developed by
facebook and is used to run tests on
react applications to ensure that they
are bug free now it is embedded
typically in every react library
and requires zero configuration now
angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework
now this framework allows various
functionalities to write different kinds
of test cases
this also ensures that the application
is error free
the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha
now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be
tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast
now let's talk about community support
since all these tools are
open source they have a large developer
community there are a few
popular github repositories for react
such as react.js 101
react.js.org and so on you can raise
queries
solve a few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular
view also has a few popular repositories
you can commit
download third party plugins and also
explore these stacks even deeper
all of them surely have a very happening
community at the time of writing
there were about 1 million repositories
5 million comments and 1 million
issues with respect to react here are
the figures for angular
and here are the figures for vue
according to npm stat
over the past two years there have been
approximately 360 million react.js
downloads
there have been around 38 million
downloads for angular and around 63
million downloads for view
now let's look at the future scope
learning a new technology
always comes with questions like what's
in it for me what's its growth potential
how far will it take me in my career and
so on so let's go ahead and see the
growth rate of react
angular and vue according to google
trends over the past
12 months react has been on a way faster
upward trajectory than angular and view
which have considerably lost their
momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity
industry adoption and community support
in today's video
we're going to learn about angular 10.
well
you must be aware that angular released
a new version
that is angular version 10 in june of
2020
so in this video we're going to talk
about the new improvements
additions and applications that come
with angular 10.
so now let's look at what's in store for
us
first we'll look at the previous angular
versions
next we look at what's new with angular
10
and finally i'll let you know how to
update to angular 10.
first up let's have a look at the
previous angular versions
ever since its inception angular has
been consistent
with releasing new features in their
versions
first up was angular 1 then angular 2
4 however angular 3 was kept there was
angular 5 and angular 6
angular 7 8 9 and finally
in 2020 they released angular 10.
angular 1 point x
also known as angularjs was a javascript
based
open source front-end web application
framework
now it aimed at simplifying both the
development
and the testing of applications by
providing a framework for client-side
model view controller it aims to
simplify both the development
and the testing of applications by
providing a framework
for model view controller and model view
view model architectures
next up angular 2 was released which was
written entirely
in typescript angular 1.x was not
built with mobile support in mind
whereas with angular 2 it came with
mobile support
now angular 3 was kept due to certain
discrepancies
with angular 4 the release was made
backward compatible
with two point x point x for most of the
applications
now there was no major change in angular
4 from angular
2. next up is angular 5. now angular 5
version
concentrated on making angular smaller
and faster to use
http client library build optimizer
and compiler improvements were made with
angular 6
the angular cli was released new
commands like ng update and ng
add were introduced now angular 7
released in october 2017 came with
performance improvements
and some interesting features like cli
prompts
virtual scrolling and drag and drops
with angular 8 that was released in 2019
features like builder apis web worker
support
and dynamic imports to name a few were
introduced
also features like iv renderer and bazel
were introduced
moving on to angular 9 is this was
released in february 2020
angular 9 came up with the most awaited
iv
compiler now its advantages were faster
testing
better debugging improved css class and
style binding
improved type checking improved build
errors
improved build times and improved
internationalization
it came with better framework and
angular material
and now the latest version that is
angular 10 was released
in june 2020 so now let's look at the
new features of angular 10 a little
deeply
so what's new with angular 10 first up
older versions of typescript are not
supported
so the previous versions of angular
supported typescript 3.6
3.7 and 3.8 but with angular 10
typescript was bumped to the version 3.9
ts lib has been updated to version 2.0
and ts lint has been updated to version
6.
next up is warnings about common js
imports
now logging of unknown property bindings
or elements
which were previously warnings have been
now increased to the error level
this change may have an effect on tools
that are not expecting an error log
the most important update of all is that
version 10 offers a new strict project
setup
when you create a new workspace with the
ng new command
now generally you have the ng new
project name command
however you can have additional setting
that is ng new
strict setting this flag initializes
your new project
with few new settings that improve
maintainability
help you catch bugs ahead of time and
allow the cli
to perform advanced optimizations on
your application
specifically the strict flag does the
following
it enables strict mode in typescript
it turns template type checking to
strict it configures your app to be side
effect free
next up is the ngcc feature
now with angular 10 there has been an
implementation
of a program based entry point finder
so what exactly is an entry point finder
now this is a point where the first
instructions of a program
are executed and this indicates that the
program has access to the command line
arguments so with angular 10
this feature has been implemented using
a program based entry point finder
now this is designed to only process
entry points that can be reached
by a program defined by your config.json
file
next up is compiler update in the latest
angular version
a compiler interface has been added in
order to wrap
the actual ngtse compiler
angular version 10 has added name spans
for property reads and method calls
next up is url routing updation
well returning null from a url matcher
would throw the type null is not
assignable to type url match result
before
this is fixed but the return type can
now be null
too next up is deprecated apis
now angular 10 has seen deprecation of
esm5 bundles
which saves up to 120 mb of download and
install time
while running beyond or npm installed
for angular packages and libraries
we will also see a deprecation of older
browsers
including internet explorer 9 10 and
internet explorer mobile that are based
on heavy consultation with the community
next up is bug fixes with this angular
10 version
there have been a number of bug fixes
that includes
compiler avoiding undefined expressions
in an
array the core avoiding a migration
error
when a non-existent symbol is being
imported
now another crucial bug fix ensures
proper identification of
modules affected by overrides in test
bed
next improvement is no default browser
configuration
now browser configuration for new
projects have been updated
to outdo older and less used browsers
one simply has to add the required
browsers
in the dot browser list file to enable
es5 builds and differential loading for
browsers
next up is core all the warnings will
now be locked in
as errors now generic has been made
mandatory
for module with providers the next
improvement
is converting free iv code
now all the pre-iv dependencies from nbm
should be transformed to iv dependencies
now this is supposed to take place as a
precursor
for running ngtse at the application and
lastly
we have service workers now
in the previous versions there were
situations where the service worker
never got registered
when there was a long running task or a
recurring timeout
however this error has been fixed in
this version
well if you've worked extensively with
angular over the past couple of years
and have now updated to the new version
then these improvements are way more
visible
so for the ones who haven't updated let
me tell you how to update
to angular 10. now you can go back to
your command
prompt and here run the command
ng update
at angular
slash cli and at angular slash
core now this must update your version
to angular 10
it installs all the packages for tooling
this might take a while
and once the installation is complete
you can go ahead and check for the
version
just type in the command ng hyphen
version
and there you go it says version 10.0.4
in this video i present you some
commonly asked angular interview
questions
now let's begin i've classified the
questions into two sections
one is the beginner level questions and
one is the advanced level questions
so now let's begin with beginner level
questions
starting with the most basic what
exactly is angular
now angular is an open source javascript
front-end framework
which is completely written in
typescript this framework
brings a structure and consistency to
web applications
and provides excellent scalability and
maintainability
now it's primarily aimed to develop
single page applications
and is maintained by google it uses html
syntax to express your application's
components clearly
it is designed for web desktop and
mobile platforms
next up is what exactly is typescript
now typescript is a superset of
javascript
that offers excellent consistency it is
highly recommended as it provides
some syntactic sugar and makes the code
base more comfortable to understand and
maintain
ultimately typescript code compiles down
to javascript
that can run efficiently in any
environment
now typically typescript is installed as
an npm package
and thus can be installed with the
following command that is npm
install hyphen g typescript
moving on to our third question what
exactly is data binding and which type
of data binding does angular deploy
now data binding is a phenomenon that
allows any internet user
to manipulate web page elements now it
generally uses dynamic html
and does not require any complex
scripting or programming
we use data binding in pages that
contain interactive components such as
forms calculators tutorials and games
data binding makes incremental display
of a web page more convenient
when it comes to angular it uses the
two-way data binding
any changes made to the user interface
are reflected in the corresponding model
state
conversely any changes in the model
state are reflected in the ui state
this allows the framework to connect the
dom to the model data via the controller
next question what are single page
applications
now single page applications are web
applications
that load just once with new features
just being mere additions to the user
interface
it does not load new html pages
to display the content instead it's
generated dynamically
this is made possible through
javascript's ability to manipulate the
dom
elements on the existing page itself
an spa approach is faster thus providing
a seamless user experience differentiate
between
angular and angularjs now here's a
simple table for you
so here are the features that we're
going to differentiate
the two on the basis of first is
language
angularjs uses javascript while angular
uses typescript when it comes to
architecture angularjs supports the
model view controller design
while angular uses components and
directives
angularjs is not supported by mobile
browsers
while angular supports all mobile
browsers
angularjs does not support dependency
injection while
angular does when it comes to routing
ad route provider is used to provide
routing information in the case of
angularjs
and in case of angular at route
configuration is used to define routing
information
when it comes to management angularjs is
difficult to manage with an increase in
source code size
while angular is better structured easy
to create
and can manage bigger applications
next up what are decorators in angular
decorators are a design pattern or
functions that define how angular
features work
now they are used to make prior
modifications to a class
service or filter angular supports four
types of decorators
namely class decorators property
decorators
method decorators and parameter
decorators
next question mention some advantages of
angular
first up is custom components now
angular enables users
to build their own components that can
pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
this is achieved with the help of these
components
data binding as discussed earlier
angular enables users to effortlessly
move data from javascript
code to the view and react to users
events
without having to write any code
manually
angular supports dependency injection
which enables users
to write modular services and inject
them wherever they need it
when it comes to testing tests are
first-class tools and angular has been
built from ground up
with testability in mind you will have
the ability to test
every part of your application and that
is highly recommended
next up is comprehensive angular is a
full-fledged framework
and provides out-of-the-box solutions
for server communication
routing with your application and more
lastly angular is cross-platform and
compatible with multiple browsers
an angular application can typically run
on all browsers be it chrome
firefox safari and operating systems
like windows mac os
and linux what's new with angular 10
first up is that older versions of
typescript are not supported
previous versions of angular supported
typescript 3.6
3.7 and even 3.8 but with angular 10
typescript bumped to typescript 3.9
warnings about common js imports now
logging of
unknown property bindings or element
names in templates
is increased to the error level which
was previously a warning
angular now supports an optional strict
setting which offers a stricter project
setup
when you create a new workspace
there's an addition of ngcc features
with a program based entry point finder
there are common compiler updates and
updated url routing
angular 10 has several deprecated apis
that were previously redundant
with angular 10 version there have been
a number of bug fixes
important ones being the compiler
avoiding undefined expressions
and the core avoiding a migration error
new default browser configuration
browser configuration for new projects
has been upgraded
to outdoor older and less used browsers
next up is core all the warnings will be
now
logged in as errors next update is
converting pre-iv code
now all the pre-iv dependencies from npm
should be transformed to iv dependencies
which is supposed to take place as a
precursor to running
ngtse at the application
and lastly we have service workers for
the service worker a fix has been put in
for a situation in which there was a
chance that the service worker would not
register when there is a long running
task or a recurring timeout
next up is what are templates in angular
now angular templates are written with
html
that contains angular specific elements
and attributes
now in combination with model and
controllers information
these templates can be rendered to
provide a dynamic view to the user
now templates are a very predominant
feature of angular
that describe how information can be
displayed in the view
next question is what are annotations in
angular
now these annotations are used to create
an annotation
array they are basically the metadata
set on the class
that is used to reflect the metadata
library
what are directives in angular
directives are attributes
that allow the user to write new html
syntax
specific to their applications now these
execute whenever the angular compiler
finds them in the dom
now again angular supports three
different types of directives
there are component directives attribute
directives and structural directives
next up what is aot compilation and what
are some of its advantages
now aots that stands for ahead of time
compiler
basically converts the angular html and
typescript
into javascript code during the build
phase
that is before the browser downloads and
runs the code
so basically all the html and typescript
code
is converted to javascript during the
build phase which means no additional
time is spent on converting it into
javascript later during the run phase
right so when it comes to advantages of
course there's faster rendering
there are fewer asynchronous requests it
has smaller angular framework download
size
there's quick detection of errors and
this also offers better security
moving on to the next question what are
components
now components are the most basic
building blocks
of the ui in an angular application now
every component is associated with a
template
and is a subset of directives only one
component can be instantiated
per element in a template now
an angular application typically
consists of a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
now every component is decorated with
the help of at component decorator which
provides additional information
and component must belong to the ng
module
lastly components implement something
called the life cycle hooks
you will learn about them a little later
in the video
next up what are pipes in angular
now pipes are simple functions that are
designed to
accept a particular input value process
this value
and return an output which is a
transformed value
now angular supports several built-in
pipes
however you can also create custom pipes
that cater to your needs but to speak
about a few saline features
pipes are defined using the pipe symbol
pipes can be chained with other pipes
and pipes can be provided with arguments
by using the colon sign
next up what are pure pipes now these
pipes
are pipes that use pure functions
as a result of this a pure pipe doesn't
use
any internal state and the output
remains the same
as long as the parameters past stay the
same
angular calls a pure pipe only when it
detects a change in the parameters being
passed
now a single instance of a pure pipe is
used throughout
all components next up
what are impure pipes now for every
change detection cycle in angular
these impure pipes are called regardless
of the change in the input fields
as long as there's a change detected
these pipes are called
as a result multiple pipe instances are
created for these pipes
now inputs passed to these pipes can
also be mutable
by default all pipes are pure however
you can also
mention impure pipes using the pure
property
now here's a code for specifying impure
pipes
you can use the pure property and either
mention true or false
true meaning it's a pure pipe and false
indicates that it's an impure pipe
next up what is the pipe transform
interface
now as the name suggests the interface
receives an input value
and transforms it into the desired
format with a transform method
it is typically used to implement custom
pipes
now here's again a small piece of code
now you can see that the pipe transform
interface is being used
which in turn executes the transform
method now this transform method is the
one that is responsible to
change your input and give a transformed
output
moving on what is ng module
now ng modules are basically containers
that reserve a block of code to an
application domain
or a workflow now the at ng module
takes a metadata object that describes
how to compile a components template
and generate an injector at runtime
in addition to this ng module also
identifies
the modules components detectives
services
pipes and also ensures that it makes
them public
so that external components can use them
all of this is taken care of
by the ng module next up
what are filters in angular
now filters are used to format an
expression
and present it to the user they can be
used in view templates
controllers or services now to name a
few
there's date filter which formats a date
to a specified format
there's filter filter that selects a
subset of items from an array
there's the json filter which formats an
object
to adjacent string there's limit 2 which
limits an array or a string into a
specified number of elements or
characters
then there's lowercase which formats a
string to lowercase
and so on moving on to the next question
what is view encapsulation in angular
now view encapsulation basically defines
whether the template and styles defined
within the component
can affect the application or vice versa
angular provides three encapsulation
strategies
there's emulated encapsulation which
means that the styles from the main html
propagate to the component then there is
native which indicates that the styles
from the main html do not propagated the
component
meaning it does not affect the component
and lastly there's none
which means that styles from the
component propagate back to the
main html and therefore are visible to
all the components on the page
now this indicates any different types
of changes and how it is affecting the
entire application
moving on what are controllers now as
the name suggests
controllers control the data of angular
applications
they are regular javascript objects and
the ng-controller directive defines the
application controller
next question what do you understand by
scope in angular
now the scope in angular binds the html
that is basically the view and the
javascript that is the controller
it is also an object with the available
properties and methods required for your
application
now when you make a controller in
angular you pass the dollar scope object
as an argument
moving on to the most commonly asked
question explain the life cycle hooks in
angular
as discussed earlier every component in
angular has a life cycle
angular creates and renders these
components and also destroys them
before removing them from the document
object model
it is achieved with the help of these
life cycle hooks
now let's have a look at them first up
is ng on changes
now this responds when angular sets or
resets
data bound input properties
ng on it is a hook that initializes
the directive or a component after
angular first displays
the data bound properties and sets the
components input properties
ng do check detects and acts upon the
changes that angular can't
or won't detect on its own
ng after content init responds after
ng projects external content into the
components view
ng after content checked response after
angular checks the content projected
into the component
ng after viewing it responds after
angular initializes
the components views and child views
ng after view checked responds after
angular checks the components views and
the child views
lastly there's ng on destroy which
cleans up
just before angular destroys the
directive or the component
moving on to the next question what is
string interpolation in angular
now string interpolation is a one-way
data binding technique
that is used by angular now it outputs
the data from typescript code to html
view
it is typically denoted with the help of
curly braces
and it helps display data from the
component to the view
to help you understand it's working i've
created a variable
called name here in my app.component.ts
file
and initialized it to simplylon and back
in my html file
i've created a heading tag
a header tag which displays the name of
the company is
and i have interpolated here with the
help of double curly braces
so when i run the file the output looks
something like this
the name of the company is simply learn
so this is how string interpolation is
achieved
in angular moving on to next question
what are template statements
template statements are properties or
methods used in html
for responding to user events now with
these template statements
the application that you create or
you're working on
can have the capability to engage users
through
actions such as submitting forms or
displaying dynamic content
most common example is the button tag
the template here is delete hero this
method is called when the user clicks on
the button
so this brings interactivity to your
application
with that we come to the end of the
first section which included the
beginner level questions
moving on let's look at some advanced
level questions
what is the difference between ahead of
time and just in time compilation
now ahead of time compilation converts
your code during the build time
before the browser downloads and runs
the code
in case of just in time compilation this
process is a way of compiling computer
code
to machine code during the execution
phase
aot ensures faster rendering to the
browser
while just in time is basically a
dynamic compilation
in case of ahead of time compiling the
user should include the hyphen hyphen
aot option with the ng build or ng serve
command
and jit compilation is the default
compilation when you run the ng build or
ng serve cli commands
next up explain the add component
decorator
now here's a simple screenshot of what
that component
decorator encompasses is it is basically
a typescript class
that is used to create components
this genre of class is then decorated
with the at
component decorator the decorators
purpose is to accept a metadata
object that provides relevant
information about
the component now the image above shows
an app component
which is a pure typescript class
decorated with that component decorator
the object that gets accepted by the
decorator provides properties like
template url selectors style urls
and many more now here the template url
property
points to an html file defining what you
see
on the application moving ahead
what are services in angular angular
services
perform tasks that are used by multiple
components
now these tasks could be data fetching
network connections
or database management among others they
perform
all the operational tasks for the
components and avoid
rewriting of code a service can be
written once and then
injected into all the components that
use it
generally components are used to only
display information
on the ui they do not perform any other
back-end tasks
to perform tasks like validating
information
or network connections etc you can make
use of a service
one advantage is that this service can
be injected into multiple components
that make use of the same piece of code
with this you can avoid redundancy
moving on
what are promises and observables now
while both the components deal with
asynchronous events in angular
promises handle one such event at a time
while
observables handle a sequence of events
over
some time so to give you a brief
explanation promises emit a single value
at a time
while observables are only executed when
subscribed to them using the subscribe
method
now promises also execute immediately
after they are created
and they are not cancelable while
observables help perform operations like
for each
filter retry etc promises
push errors to the child promises and
observables can be unsubscribed to
so that the listener stops receiving
further values
next up what is ng on init and how is it
defined
now again here's a small snippet of code
ng on init is a life cycle hook as we
discussed earlier
and there is a callback method that is
run by angular
to indicate that a component has been
created
it takes no parameters and returns a
void type
so i'm sure you can see here in the code
it takes no parameters and returns a
void
next up explain the use of ng4
in a tag or explain
the ng for director now
the ng for directive is basically
like a for loop it is used to build
lists and tables and html templates so
in
simple terms this directive is used to
iterate over an
array or an object and create template
for each such element
now in the snippet you can see there is
let items in item list
and then i have string interpolated the
variable item so let item here creates a
local variable
that will be available inside the
template of
items indicates that we are iterating
over the items iterable
and the asterisk before ng4 creates a
parent template
next up what are template and reactive
forms so there are two different methods
to create
forms we have the template driven
approach and we have the reactive form
approach
so let's have a look at them in case of
template driven approach
the conventional form tag is used to
create forms
angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object
representation for this tag controls can
be added to the form
using the ng model tag multiple controls
can be
grouped using the ng control group
module
now a form value can be generated using
the form dot value object
and form data is exported as json values
basic html validations can be used to
validate the form fields
in the case of custom validations
directives can be used
when it comes to reactive forms this
approach
basically revolves around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
the active forms are code driven unlike
template-driven approach
reactive forms break the traditional
declarative approach
and eliminate the anti-pattern of
updating data via the two-way data
binding method
typically reactive form control creation
is synchronous
and can be unit tested with synchronous
programming techniques
moving on what is bootstrap how is it
added to angular
now bootstrap is a powerful toolkit it
is a collection of
basic html css and javascript tools
for creating and building responsive web
applications
there are two ways to embed bootstrap
libraries
first up is using the bootstrap cdn
which is the content delivery network
now this enables users to load the css
and javascript files
remotely from its servers the other way
is
to use angular bootstrap via npm
now this is used to add bootstrap to
your angular project
by installing it into your project
folder
now you can use commands like npm
install bootstrap
and npm install jquery to install them
for your project
if you wish to learn bootstrap in detail
i highly suggest you check out our video
on
angular bootstrap the tutorial explains
how to embed bootstrap and user to
create and good looking angular
applications
what is eager and lazy loading
eager loading is the default module
loading strategy
now all the feature modules under eager
loading are loaded before your
application even starts
this is typically used for small size
applications since lesser
modules are used all of these modules
are loaded
initially which makes running of these
kind of applications extremely fast when
it comes to lazy loading
all the loading happens dynamically all
feature modules are loaded on demand
it is used for bigger applications where
the modules are not required at the
start of applications
this makes the application faster since
no time is spent on loading unnecessary
modules
next up what type of dom does angular
implement
dom or document object model treats an
xml or html document as a tree structure
in which each node is an object
representing a part of the document
now angular uses the regular dom this
updates the entire tree structure
of html tags until it reaches the data
that has to be updated
now to ensure that the speed and
performance are not affected
angular implements something called as a
change detection
next up how is dependency injection
achieved in angular
now dependencies are objects or services
that a component needs to perform
functions correct now with the help of
dependency injection these classes
can request dependencies from external
sources rather than creating them on
their own
here i've created a service called demo
service using the command
ngg service demo service and i've also
added a small snippet of code when
you create that service
now these services can be injected to
your
main component and perform various
functions
next up how does angular routing work
now i am sure you must have observed
that the url changes
every time you click on your user
interface on an application
correct every time you navigate through
the application or move from one page to
another
the url changes now this means
that the application is being routed or
you're navigating through the
application
so basically routing helps navigate
through a web application
especially in case of single page
applications now as discussed earlier
single page applications are loaded just
once
so any new content that is being
displayed is just a mere
addition it's not being loaded again so
routing plays a vital role in case of
single page applications typically it is
specified with the help of the forward
slash
and followed by a path that defines a
new content
now i'm just taking the same example
that i took before
uh this was the example for string
interpolation however you can see that
we have a navigation bar here
with four different options for that is
home about services and login
and for home and login i've created a
path
and added routing to it so when i click
on the home icon
you can see that some content is being
displayed onto the screen
and if you observe you can see that
there is a forward slash with
the path name home here which indicates
that routing has occurred
same with login when i click on it the
path changes
and the login page appears if you wish
to learn
the concept of routing i suggest you
check out a video
the tutorial explains routing in detail
moving on what are form control and form
groups
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
and these instances help check the
values of the field
and see if they are touched untouched
dirty pristine
valid invalid and so on so for every
field
in the form the data that is being
provided is validated with the help of
these controls
if it is dirty it means that the value
has been changed
if the data provided holds good for a
particular condition
then the control is set to be valid
and so on with the help of these
controls you can determine if the value
provided is legitimate or not
this can be achieved with the help of
form control
when it comes to form group and the form
group class represents a group of
controls
number form can have multiple control
groups
the form group class returns true if all
the controls are valid
and also provides validation errors if
any
next up is how is testing achieved in
angular
now angular uses jasmine to run various
tests
the jasmine framework allows various
functionalities
to write different kinds of test cases
the task runner for these tests is
typically
karma and karma uses a configuration
file
to set the startup reporters and the
testing framework
next question is what is package.json
now npm installs package.json when a new
workspace is created
now this file includes a starter set of
packages
some of which are required by angular
now typically it's organized into two
groups one is
dependencies these are essential to run
your applications
and we have dev dependencies these are
essential to develop
applications so with that we come to the
end of this video
i hope it helped you get a good hold of
angular fundamentals
if you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comment section below
thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here